>>> OKAY, EVERYONE, SIT DOWN AND
WATCH THIS, BECAUSE I NEVER
THOUGHT I WOULD BE IN THIS
POSITION TO MAYBE SOMEHOW HAVE
TO DEFEND TUCKER CARLSON.
BUT WE'LL SEE WHERE THIS GOES.
I HAVE MIXED EMOTIONS ABOUT THIS
ONE.
FOX PROPAGANDA HOST TUCKER
CARLSON CONFRONTED IN A MONTANA
FISHING SHOP, CALLED THE WORST
HUMAN BEING KNOWN TO MAN.
THE MAN POSTED THE CONFRONTATION
TO HIS INSTAGRAM POST.
HE ACCUSED CARLSON OF VACCINE
MISINFORMATION AND SUPPORTING
RACISM.
>> IT'S NOT EVERY DAY YOU GET TO
TELL SOMEONE THEY ARE THE WORST
HUMAN BEING.
>> YOU ARE THE WORST HUMAN BEING
KNOWN TO MAN.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT.
>> MY DAUGHTER'S HERE.
>> I DON'T CARE, MAN.
DUDE, YOU ARE THE WORST HUMAN
BEING KNOWN TO MAN.
>> I APPRECIATE THAT.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
>> WHAT YOU HAVE DONE TO
EVERYBODY ELSE --
>> OKAY.
>> OKAY, SO FOX NEWS REACTING IN
A STATEMENT SAYING, AMBUSHING
TUCKER CARLSON WHILE IN A STORE
WITH HIS FAMILY IS TOTALLY
INEXCUSABLE, NO PUBLIC FIGURE
SHOULD BE ACCOSTED REGARDLESS OF
THEIR POLITICAL PERSUASION OR
BELIEFS SIMPLY DUE TO THE
INTOLERANCE OF ANOTHER POINT OF
VIEW.
THE STORE WHERE IT HAPPENED IS
CALLED DAN BAILEY'S OUTDOOR
COMPANY, IT ISSUED A PUBLIC
STATEMENT SAYING EVEN THOUGH
THEY HAVE THE SAME NAME, THEY
SHARE NO AFFILIATION WITH THE
DAN BAILEY IN THE VIDEO, IT'S A
COINCIDENCE THAT IT'S THE SAME
NAME.
ANA NAVARRO AND SCOTT JENNINGS
ARE BOTH HERE.
THANK YOU BOTH SO MUCH.
LET ME TELL YOU THIS, I DON'T
LIKE IT WHEN PEOPLE DO THAT
BECAUSE YOU WOULDN'T WANT PEOPLE
TO DO IT TO ME.
BUT TUCKER HAS DONE THESE THINGS
TO OTHER PEOPLE.
TUCKER SAID SOME NASTY THINGS
ABOUT ME AND THE NEXT DAY THERE
WERE PAPARAZZI OUTSIDE MY HOUSE,
HIDING, TAKING PICTURES.
I DON'T WANT IT TO HAPPEN TO
ANYONE, I DON'T WANT IT TO
HAPPEN TO TUCKER, BUT WHEN YOU
DO THINGS LIKE THAT, I DON'T
KNOW, THAT'S THE REAL DEAL,
THAT'S HOW I FEEL ABOUT IT.
ANA, WE'RE ALL ON TV.
WE'VE BEEN APPROACHED.
WE HEAR GOOD THINGS, WE HEAR BAD
THINGS FROM PEOPLE.
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO THEY ARE,
IT'S PART OF THE GIG.
DON'T YOU THINK THIS WENT A
LITTLE TOO FAR, THOUGH?
>> UMM, YOU KNOW, I ACTUALLY
THOUGHT THE GUY WHO CONFRONTED
HIM WAS QUITE POLITE, WAS NOT
SHOUTING, WAS NOT VIOLENT, WAS
NOT AGGRESSIVE IN ANY WAY.
HE EXPRESSED HIS OPINION IN THE
SAME WAY THAT TUCKER
CARLSON
EXPRESSES HIS OPINION.
IT HAPPENED TO ME, THERE WAS A
LADY STALKING ME, SHE WANTED TO
INSULT ME FOR LOATHING TRUMP.
>> BUT I DON'T THINK THAT SHOULD
HAPPEN TO YOU, ANA, I DON'T
THINK IT SHOULD HAPPEN TO CHRIS
OR ME OR SCOTT.
>> DON, I ALSO DON'T THINK THERE
SHOULD BE HURRICANES OR THERE
SHOULD BE COVID.
BUT CRAP HAPPENS, OKAY?
WE GET REMUNERATED FOR GIVING
OUR OPINION AND THAT COMES WITH
GOOD AND THAT COMES WITH BAD.
SO PUT ON YOUR BIG BOY PANTS OR
YOUR BIG GIRL PANTS AND GET ON
WITH LIFE.
WHEN IT COMES TO TUCKER CARLSON,
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE OR IMMIGRATION OR
YOU NAME IT.
IT'S ABOUT COVID AND IT'S ABOUT
LIFE AND DEATH.
I THINK PEOPLE ARE VERY RAW AND
EMOTIONAL AND ANGRY ABOUT THAT
IN PARTICULAR.
SO I THINK THAT WITH THE
PLATFORM WE ALL HAVE, SCOTT,
YOU, ALL OF US, TUCKER, I, HAVE,
COMES THE BENEFIT OF SOME PEOPLE
LIKING WHAT WE SAY AND SOME
PEOPLE NOT LIKING WHAT WE SAY.
IN THE SAME WAY I HAVE A FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT, THEY HAVE A
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT.
DEAL WITH IT.
>> BUT FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT
DOESN'T MEAN INVADING MY
PERSONAL SPACE, I'M SORRY, ANA.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
AND I GET IT.
I THINK WHAT TUCKER SAYS MUCH OF
THE TIME IS COMPLETELY
REPREHENSIBLE AND DIVORCED FROM
REALITY.
BUT HE HAS A RIGHT TO BE IN A
SPACE AND NOT BE ACCOSTED AND
NOT BE AMBUSHED BY ANYONE.
PEOPLE YELL ALL THE TIME AT ME.
I WAS IN CINCINNATI, THERE WERE
TRUMP SUPPORTERS OUT THERE
YELLING ACROSS, WHATEVER.
THEY WEREN'T IN MY FACE.
IF YOU WANT TO STAND ACROSS THE
STREET, FINE.
>> THERE WAS ONE PERSON WHO MADE
CONTACT THERE.
IT WAS TUCKER CARLSON WITH A
GUY.
THE GUY NEVER TOUCHED TUCKER
CARLSON.
THE GUY NEVER ACCOSTED TUCKER
HE GAVE TUCKER CARLSON HIS
OPINION ABOUT WHAT HE SAID AND
IT IS WHAT WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
FOR GIVING OUR OPINION EVERY
NIGHT.
>> I HEAR YOU.
AND TUCKER CARLSON SAYS IF YOU
SEE A KID WEARING A MASK, YOU
SHOULD CALL THE COPS.
I GET IT.
>> IF YOU'RE GOING TO DISH IT,
YOU BETTER BE ABLE TO TAKE IT.
>> SCOTT, FOX NEWS CALLED IT AN
AMBUSH.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, I AGREE, IT WAS AN
AMBUSH.
I THOUGHT TUCKER HANDLED IT
FINE.
HE'S BEEN APPROACHED BEFORE.
AND HE USUALLY FINDS A WAY TO
DEFUSE IT AND LAUGH IT OFF.
I THOUGHT THE GUY ACTUALLY
LOOKED PRETTY AGGRESSIVE, HE GOT
RIGHT IN HIS FACE, WAS CHEST TO
CHEST WITH HIM, LOOKED LIKE HE
WAS TRYING TO MOVE WITH TUCKER
AS TUCKER WAS TRYING TO GET
AWAY.
I HAD A SIMILAR REACTION TO YOU,
DON, I DON'T WANT THIS TO HAPPEN
TO TUCKER CARLSON BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT IT TO HAPPEN TO YOU.
YOU BY THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HAVE BEEN
PERSONALLY SINGLED OUT, PEOPLE
AT CNN HAVE BEEN PERSONALLY
SINGLED OUT.
THERE'S A WHOLE GROUP OF FOLKS
WHO WOULD LOVE TO GET IN THE
FACE OF PEOPLE HERE AND OTHERS
OUT THERE WHO WOULD LOVE TO GET
IN THE FACE OF PEOPLE ON FOX
NEWS OR MSNBC.
TO RATIONALIZE IT OR LAUGH IT
OFF OR SAY PUT ON YOUR BIG BOY
PANTS, TO ME IS CONDONE IT.
IF YOU WANT TO CONDONE A
CONFRONTATION LIKE THIS, YOU'RE
INVITING THE NEXT ONE AND THE
NEXT PERSON MAY NOT HAVE THE
SAME PHYSICAL RESTRAINT.
DON, YOU'VE MET PEOPLE I'M SURE
OUT THERE WHO LOOK LIKE THEY
WOULD LOVE TO COMMIT VIOLENCE.
WHEN YOU ENCOURAGE THESE KINDS
OF CONFRONTATIONS OR CONDONE IT,
I THINK THE NEXT ONE MAY NOT BE
SO FRIENDLY AND PEOPLE MAY LAY
HANDS ON EACH OTHER AND THAT
MAKES ME EXTREMELY
UNCOMFORTABLE.
I DON'T MIND THIS GUY'S VIEWS,
HE'S WELCOME TO HAVE THEM, BUT
IN A SPACE LIKE THAT, TUCKER'S
DAUGHTER WAS THERE, IN A SMALL
STORE, IT MADE ME UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> MY RESPONSE IS ALWAYS, THANK
YOU FOR WATCHING, I'M SO GLAD,
THANK YOU SO MUCH, EVEN IF THEY
SAY THE WORST THINGS ABOUT ME
BECAUSE REALLY I WANT IT DEFUSE
IT AND WANT THEM TO GO AWAY.
AGAIN, I KNOW PEOPLE HAVE THE
RIGHT.
I'M ON TV.
I GIVE MY POINT OF VIEW AND I
SAY MY TAKE ALL